yeah it's because bug crowd doesn't know that i can hack hardware i need to hit them up and be like
hey by the way he submits one bug a year on bug crowd and it's like hardware god no
yo yo we're rolling yo yo how's it going pretty good dude this uh this past couple weeks has been
kind of crazy but we're getting ready to kick off a live hacking event again so it's not going to
slow down i don't think oh dude non-stop it's it's like one thing to the next thing to the next
thing yeah well at least you got a you got a week off last week from the pod yes a little bit
barely yeah you had crazy stuff going on though so that's that's how it goes yeah yeah yeah all right
um yeah let's check out the news stuff for the day um first first up on the docket was naham khan
uh who are sponsoring this episode so thank you naham khan um just wanted to give them a shout out
and say i'm going to be speaking there on the saturday um saturday slot at 12 20 and i'm going to be
giving a presentation on uh pci dss which is essentially payment card stuff um and how pretty
much every single website that we've seen is vulnerable to some sort of trickery in this area
due to the way that the uh dss structures uh recommended structure is so there's going to be
some really really awesome content in that that will drop so definitely don't miss that on on saturday
at 12 p.m pst yeah dude i'm really looking forward to that um i know that naham always has amazing
people on for his his con and just for his show in general and all the all the content that he makes
but uh yeah it's super awesome i'm i'm super stoked to see what you talk about there i think i think the
con in particular i think is one of the one of the best structured ones for bug bounty hunters because
you know ben just has such a good network in the bug bounty hunter you know field that he can put
together a bunch of people that really know what they're talking about and have differing expertise
to share i was looking at the lineup and there's a bunch of um you know eclectic hacking styles and
you know you've got people from like influencers like stoke all the way down to you know uh people
like douglas day that just really get in their requests every single time so uh it's really it's
really cool to see the the whole the whole gamut being run there yeah yeah it should be awesome
yep um yeah oh man man the next the next item on the news list makes me so sad man i just you know
on twitter you know you see gareth hayes talk about javascript stuff all the time and he's one of those
people that like you can just feel the passion when he talks about javascript like he just freaking
loves javascript and uh and he tweeted out earlier this week and i threw it on the list that his
favorite xss vector is going to start stop working i think was it like november when they're they're
going to depreciate it uh yeah i didn't catch the exact date but 119 november 2023 um they're going
to depreciate uh data urls inside of the use element in svgs yeah yeah so for those who aren't aware
this is basically like one of the really common ways that you would pop an xss within an svg not
just like svg on error on load or whatever but within the svg element itself you can include stuff
like um you know well with this use element um you can use different different things i think it's
meant to take a bunch of different data types yeah it uses a data url here and and kind of uses that
within the within the svg itself um but it seems like they they want to have that that piece that uh
that data element removed from the svg uh use element and that would result in i guess you
potentially you could still load it externally um but then you've got csp stuff that you're going to
run into so it's it's a double-edged sword there yeah yeah i know there are a couple other
vectors and looking at the web academy the web security academy on port swigger um there there's
these ones that use animate inside of svg oh yeah and not all of them some of them do use that use
element but not all of them do so i'm wondering if that will still be a valid attack factory yeah i mean
as long as as long as it's not because the use element's still staying it's it's just that the
data url inside of the use element um is is kind of going away uh and i think i'm looking at the
reason for removal and it looks like it's largely you know because the sort of same origin issue that
that's going on there um so sad to see that go but really cool vector and i'd always love to see
uh gareth hayes talking about xss stuff i i have he's one of one of the people that i do have
notifications turned on for tweet notifications turned on for because he's just like every single
time it's super high quality research and i just i really appreciate that yeah yeah yeah i mean he's
always yeah i mean he's just like he's such a javascript like fanatic you know it's like all he
does it's like his main focus so he he's one of those people that has so much insight about the
nuance about what's going on yeah so any anything that you can do to like consume gareth's gareth's
knowledge is something i would recommend yeah and i love that little i love that i love that he wrote
a little book too you know like i feel like that's something that people that specialize in the industry
it's it's really handy because the book is not long it's not very hard to consume you know but it
outlines all this cool you know shit that he has in his brain that otherwise he wouldn't have access
to and so i definitely i definitely endorse that method not only just for knowledge sharing reasons
but also just for it's a great thing to do when you're a specialist you know take take the you
know however long it takes do a little brain dump on this topic that you're just a super expert at
and put it out there and now you've got a product that you can you know you're getting reoccurring
income from and you're also sharing that knowledge with a large community large community excuse me so
that's that's really i really respect that yeah for sure uh and we've talked about this as well in the
past like any type of the it's it doesn't have to be like groundbreaking research right but like
any of that knowledge sharing type content is really amazing for building out the community and
just like helping other hackers learn and get better and helping secure everything as a whole
quirks and sometimes it ends up being one of these things where like eventually the browsers will come
and they'll like patch something that shouldn't behave that way or whatever but like
okay yeah you know that sucks for us as hackers but it's good for security as a whole and i think like
that insight is is valuable regardless yeah dude it makes me think of that of that i man did we cover
it on the pod or did it just make it into the news list but it makes me remember this one at a
time at a live hacking event there's this guy bitk that showed me um this way that you can exfiltrate
data via via fetch um and what what you do is you you know you get it cached and then you say hey you
force fetch to use cash and it was like at the time it was just like oh this is like totally amazing
because you could get a cookie you could get a cookie to you know get the data and then it would
cash the response and then you could send the fetch request without the cookie with caching you know pull
from the cash set to mandatory and then it would pull the results back and it was just like man this
is such a genius method and so that's really smart i mean it's it's sad because you know those those
methods get deleted you know as soon as they become popular but if you're lucky enough to have met you
know a great researcher at like a live hacking event or at networking you know sometimes you can pick
up these little tidbits that will you know really help you pop some crazy bugs during engagements so
yeah yeah for sure um did you hear about this this move it uh the movement vulnerability oh my gosh
yeah it's hard to it's hard to have not not have heard of that man twitter's kind of blowing up
about it yeah yeah so i was reading about this and uh it's this like file like transfer app right
yeah yeah yeah that was my understanding i hadn't actually heard of this before like
what up move it until the vulnerability they were saying it's all over the place but i actually
hadn't seen it very much i wonder you know actually how much net presence it does have
yeah yeah it was super interesting so um i wasn't sure they said that huntress uh is that who who owns
it or is that the people who found that's i think that's um john hammond did some work with them and
i think he uh he sort of did this whole i guess sort of i don't know if this is like an incident response
yeah they call it rapid response um to this sort of vulnerability and i thought this was really cool
because um you know even and i i also linked that in the click click the twitter link in the doc right
below that joel like i love to see this sort of thing john is like out there at 4am tweeting like
oh man i can't figure out like oh is this it and he's like putting screenshots of code and i just
you know i read through that whole thread and i was like man this is why
you know he rocks this is why people you know if you can come into this with this much passion where
you're up at like 4am like you know really just trying to grind out this this poc because what
he was trying to do was reverse the poc you know reverse the flow from um i guess it looked like in
the beginning all he had was a packet cap or like a like a log of the various um endpoints that they
hit so you know if you click that that um image at the top of the tweet it's like you know it hit
move it is api.dll and then it hits a couple other things and so he's trying to like follow that flow
and figure out how they they ended up popping this this shell um so yeah it's it's amazing to see
you know when people are that into it and that like enthralled and then they look up it's like
4am and you're like ah what the heck yeah yeah no that's awesome yeah it actually looks like he works
he's a researcher at huntress so yeah yeah so super super interesting it sounds like they basically
yeah like they got a packet capture or something like that um and so they started digging into it
and trying to figure out like how it was working and and the whole chain and i don't want to like
spoil all of this because i think it's worth reading yeah they don't drop the full exploit either
which is you know for me a little bit disappointing but also you know totally reasonable i i think
surely it's already somebody's already figured it out right like yeah yeah yeah so it's a really
awesome um i feel like this would have fit perfectly with our source code analysis episodes that we just
did um but yeah this is one of those cases where you just do the deep dive you keep digging digging
going through rabbit holes trying to figure out like how does this code work how does this code work
what is this code doing and eventually you you get to the root of it and uh and it's it's really
awesome um it's a super interesting case study for sure in in terms of like how something like this
would work out in the wild um and uh i think that there's definitely some like learnings that you
could pull away from like an organizational standpoint or how could you secure your org to
protect against this like in the future like what kinds of rules and stuff would you want to keep
an eye out for are there certain traffic patterns that you should be like looking out for that might
have popped up if you were exploited by this that kind of stuff yeah he he adds like some yara rules
and like some um indicators of compromise to the to the write-up which is great too yeah um and yeah
just like you said you know about going down rabbit holes if you go to john hammond's twitter
right now and you know on on june 3rd i saw it that's the next day you know he's like oh we
finally got it and he's like ps it doesn't have anything to do with the crazy shit that i was
spewing it for him so it's like i just i feel that man and uh yeah it's it's cool to see you know
for those of you that are always thinking like oh man i'm not sure am i going down the right path
you know how do i how do i know um look at john here you know one of the most skilled guys out
there on the arena you know he does education in you know cyber security stuff all the time shout
out to his youtube channel excellent amazing youtube channel um and even he goes down these
rabbit holes and ends up you know uh this is the wrong thing so it definitely happens it's part
of the process and at the end of the day if you keep on being persistent um just like john you'll
you'll end up popping the full bug for sure yeah for sure um i think as well um it's really
interesting like i feel like i've been in that scenario so many times where i've spent like eight
hours or like more just like looking at one thing and i'm so invested that i don't want to step out of
it yeah but like do you have any what do you do when you're in that scenario well it's it's funny you
mention that because um i'm gonna actually just pull it up on my email right now there's somebody
messaged um this week uh into info at criticalthinkingpodcast.io and he said this is the question
he said when you are hunting and you're doing recon and getting a feel for the app you have something
interesting that you are poking at how do you know you are on to something promising do you have
any tips for knowing when it is time to cut bait and move on how to know when the potential uh the
potential for success is there or whether it's not worth the effort and i was like yeah that's that's
the rub right you know to just bring it back to the shakespearean i that's the rub you know whether
it is nobler to continue to pursue down your rabbit hole or to you know i forget the rest of the
quote but it's mcbeth so yeah i yeah i was not i english was maybe my least favorite class
they they made us do like a like a presentation of that and i was the guy reading that so i should
remember it but you know whether it is nobler to continue to hack or whether it is nobler to not
continue to hack um is the question and yeah it's really it's really hard to know man um and i think at
some point you know you kind of get to a point where you're like all right i've looped on my on my brain
so many times like i keep on just coming to the same conclusion same conclusion same conclusion and
for me it's probably five or ten cycles of that you know somewhere between five and ten cycles of that
before i'm like man i'm not really sure i'm gonna find anything else at this at this specific code
pathway and that's when you start working back and i will add this is one of the things that i think
was developed for me a lot by the oscp um because the oscp has a has a time limit right you know you've got
24 hours and if you spend too much time going down a rabbit hole that you can't you know that doesn't
end up with anything you've lost a bunch of time so um that is that is something that pretty much
only comes with experience i think is is knowing whether when to to cut you know cut your losses and move
on or whether there's something there um so i would say you know to the listeners that are wondering
about this question um yeah i'll just call them cg thanks for the thanks for the question cg um you
know experiment with it right so you know if you maybe you'll do one session where you're like all
right anytime i run into a wall i'm just gonna move along right and i know some people that do that
actually and and you know it works for them and that's great and i know some people that
you know if they run into a wall 15 times at the same end point they're still going to keep going
at it so you've got to figure out what is right for you as a hacker and where that limit lies and
it can be something that's intuitive uh or it can be something you know that's set in concrete saying
hey i've thought where am i going to go five times now time to move on check you know and you move
along so what do you think about that joel yeah i think i'm i'm very similar where it's not like
i'm not an instant kind of pass when it when it's pushing back a little bit yeah i do like to push
through it a little bit further just to see like am i missing something here is there something more
to this am i just doing something like you know very minor here that is blocking me up here like
sometimes i'll be like testing something for a while and i've just made like a simple error in
my request or something that's like it's the worst right you spent like an hour you're like oh i guess
this is like total and then you're like oh my god i've been using the wrong the wrong request this
whole time or something like that like yeah that's what happens to me can really help too right yeah
that extra set of eyes is so useful just having somebody who's like hey uh that's the that's the
wrong request like just that extra little second brain on your shoulder yeah that's super helpful
um but i think for me it's something like it's very similar to like what you have it's like
some it's i don't have a specific number but it's a certain number of times where i've run it and hit
the brick wall and i'm like okay i should probably move on and some of it will also depend on whether or
not i have other interesting things to be looking at i feel like that also affects my like how lenient
i am to just move on and go to the next thing because if something has been really like pulling
at me like this is something interesting i need to look at but i need to finish what i'm looking at
right now if i'm not getting anywhere with what i'm looking at right now it i'm more likely to go
start looking at that new thing no that that totally makes sense and i think i i have that same
mentality but for me i think it feels a little bit more like a surrender when i move away from it like
i i think i do have a little bit more of that fighting spirit than is good for me sometimes
you know and i've talked about this publicly on the pod before how i used to not really do that
at all and i would just move along and you know that was those were the days when i was finding a
bunch of like you know eye doors and access control stuff because i was getting a bunch of volume because
i was moving along so quickly as soon as anything would would you know bump into my way right and you
know if it's a function of volume you know for those sort of bugs because it works or it doesn't work it's
not there's no fiddling normally but um when i started you know banging my head up against a wall
sometimes when i saw an attack vector that's when i started finding these more serious volumes um that
are more deeply embedded in the apps and started walking away with some bigger bounties and you know
to be perfectly honest looking at the statistics my amount earned hasn't changed that much between
those two strategies i think it's a little bit higher where i'm at now but um you know my amount
earned does not actually deviate that much because the like we've said in before those eye doors and
those access control issues can be extremely impactful and if you can get a bunch of those it
really pays off big so it's it's really up to the individual hacker yeah so so do you have a
preference between the two in hindsight i think having done both and seeing that there's not a huge
impact on the on the earnings would you would you ever go back to the first one or no i mean i i think
my preference is strongly where i'm at now because it's more interesting and it feels more risky and
sometimes it's a little bit less you know a little bit more stressful because you're like well if this
doesn't pop then i'm screwed you know but um but you know i think as i've developed as a hacker in my
stress management and my anxiety management as well you know over bug bounty and as i've become a little
bit more financially stable as well and and you know realizing hey it's not the end of the world and
i've also just become a little bit more confident in who i am as a hacker as well you know in my identity
as a hacker um i i you know definitely lean a little bit more towards the latter now it's like oh let me let
me spend a little extra time let me find some cool shit and spend a little bit less time grinding
through the the burp requests um but i definitely recommend that in the beginning for any beginner as
well because if you can hit a lot of volume you'll see a lot of you'll see a lot of hgp requests and
like we talked about those reps lead you to be a better hacker so there's there's definitely you
know you could go either way depending on which way you want to grow yeah yeah and i think one of the
other things i recommend is especially this this happens early on a lot when you first start hacking
you're just going to be like looking at stuff and it's going to be hard to find your first bug
and moving on is really difficult because when you first start you don't know when you should move
on and like you have like no context in terms of like what what does that feel like or like where
is the right place to draw the line and so i'd say like if when you do decide like to move on
don't like don't think about it too much like don't let it beat you up because you have to remember
that like all the bug bounty is basically trying to beat the odds you're trying to like find something
that is bad that shouldn't exist and you're trying to like break the system that is designed to keep
you know customer data safe or whatever it is and so if you don't find anything it doesn't mean that
like you failed right it just means like that app might be secure and that's good and that's that's
okay and you know it's time to just move on to the next thing and find something that feels less secure
so that you can find all the holes in it you know yeah yeah and you know we preach this on the pod all
the time you know there's a whole team of people that are dedicated to you not being able to do your
job when you're doing book bounty so it's a really it's a really challenging thing but we believe in you
you got it so go get those bounties and i will say uh you know for the more experienced hackers out
there as well don't get set in your ways don't don't get so tied up in your approach that you never
that you never experiment because i know i grew a lot as a hacker as i started um experimenting away
into the more rabbit holy sort of uh find the weird shit uh sort of things rather than the volume of
of requests um so i think there's a lot of room for growth there as you experiment with um the various
techniques yeah 100 nice man well we that was that was a nice little little vibe we deviated a little
bit from the plan but i'm glad we talked about that because that's that's just really important
things yeah for sure um all right so this is what i had on on on the plan for today joel um we did
as we mentioned before we've done a good bit of hardware hacking lately um with a live hacking event
that uh we last went to so this is the episode where we talk a little bit more about that where we
give some details on some of the techniques that we used and uh kind of go into detail um so i mean
we could start with the hardware recon is that does that work for you joel you got anywhere else you
want to start no let's let's let's start from the top you know yeah so um click click that link
that's about that's uh in under the um the next bullet point there uh because i wanted to ask you
something specifically about this so you know if you scroll down um and we'll link this link this is
uh this is river loop securities hardware uh hacking right up you know you scroll down and eventually
they're soldering onto test pins on the back side of an emmc emmc chip right yep um so for those of
you that just that just sounded like garbage uh emmc is an embedded multimedia card is that right
i think uh yes yes embedded multimedia card yeah um and and that is sort of like the hard drive of
these iot applications where they're storing the file system it's the non-volatile storage right
um and so one of the reasons we want to get at that is because it contains the source code uh in in the
actual file system for the iot device we can be really insightful to us as hackers um so uh what i
wanted to talk i wanted i wanted to ask you joel in this sort of hardware recon section is like there
are these test pins on the back of that and we can use those if we can find these test pins that
correlate to this emmc protocol i guess we can use those to read from the emmc chip as well and we
don't even have to pull the chip right off the board is that right yes so in some cases yes some
cases no yeah they talk about it a little bit so typically if you want to read off of them off an
mmc chip while it's like in use that's probably not a great idea okay for a couple reasons it would
be basically like trying to read a hard drive while it's plugged in and being used so there are other
operations happening on the drive at the same time from a different like from the host os that hasn't
mounted and so it might be reading and writing at the same time it might be performing operations it
might have stuff locked like you never know and there might be like conflicting data with the
controller within the email with the mm within the mmc that will cause it to like have problems so
sometimes that works sometimes it doesn't but it's really good for at least at the minimum like
looking at like debug like what's going on like is this are these pins the right pins is this chip
functional like am i looking in the right area all that kind of stuff but it's potentially possible
to use those test points um to interact with the chip if we can figure out a way to have the chip
um activated you know with with power um right and not have the cpu you know hitting that same bus is
that is that right right yeah so like to the best of my understanding you could literally just pull up
the spec for that chip read through it see what the voltage is supposed to be see what the amperage
is supposed to be take out a dc power supply set it to the right voltage and amperage connect it to the
vcc and ground and power it up power the power it up yeah yeah and then okay so that's cool because
that that actually gives us a second a second um sort of route to get or i guess maybe a third or
fourth route depending on how much stuff we get to cover today but um essentially for me as a more of a
more of a beginner i i feel like i've kind of got a grip on some of the hardware hacking stuff now
but what what my playbook kind of looked like was like okay is there a uart interface on this device
so you search around you look for the uart interface and we'll talk about uart and jtag on a different
episode that'll be um a hardware hacking episode too but um and then if you can't find those then you
just do a a chip pull and throw it into a reader and then try to pull the operating system off and
that way but there's actually another method that doesn't destroy your device because that's the
problem with the chip off method is it destroys your device and if you can use if you can you know
solder some pins onto these uh uh onto these sort of test test pins there or solder some connectors
onto those test pins and hook that up to a um some sort of device that can communicate over emmc
then uh and i think in this in this uh blog that we'll link in the description they use a logic analyzer
here to figure out which um which individual pin correlates to what part of the emmc right um then
you could potentially get a file system read through through that and it would still come across as like
an sd card to your computer right yeah so generally like i like this approach because it's very like
ground up like it doesn't require you to pull up the the data sheet or anything like that however i would
say in most cases like 99 of cases you can literally just take the chip number google it pull up the data
sheet and you know exactly what the pinout is like most of the time most of the time you you don't need
to be like figuring out which is the clock pin because they're not changing that stuff like that comes
straight from the manufacturer of the chip sure um there are cases that i've seen where uh either
there will be like uh so so typically there's a dot on top of a chip and that dot is in one of the
corners and that references which one is chip which one is pin one um and so oh interesting sometimes
they'll put a dot somewhere else or or they'll put a dot on multiple corners so you don't know which
which pin is pin one and so you have to figure it out yourself savage dude that's so savage yeah and
i'm not sure whether or not that's like purposeful or whether or not that's like just you know they
make a chip that can be used in multiple configurations so they put it you know in multiple
i don't i don't know but um i have seen that um out like i've seen pictures of that on the wild so
um that's just something to be aware of but if you have a very like straightforward chip
it is like a single dot on the top uh you can also just there are easy things you can verify so
for example every chip is going to have a voltage and a ground pin so if you take your multimeter
and you put it on continuity testing which will basically tell whether or not the signal is going
between one probe and the other probe um typically there's a way to make it so it beeps and
you tap the the leads together it goes beep right so that's continuity testing you put one lead on
the ground pin from your data sheet you read the data sheet you go okay this should be the ground pin
and then you either you can go as far back as you want you could go all the way to the power connector
and one of those pins should be power one of them should be ground and you can test and see is there
continuity between these pins yes or no and you can do the same thing for vcc and that's also how you
can test these the test pads and see is this pad pointing to this pin or this pin on the chip um and
then that's a pretty easy way to determine whether or not it's using a standard pin out or not nice
nice so i mean i guess we can do that to a certain degree with with a multimeter right and and and you
know with the continuity testing like you were talking about but when it gets to something like
for example in this article it was talking about the various pieces of emmc protocol which i'll i'll
kind of uh touch on very lightly for for the audience that haven't read the the um the write-up yet but
essentially there's three main parts of of the protocol that you need to identify there's the there's the clock
there's the cmd which is um the the line that's used for sending commands and then there's uh data zero um and that's the
the minimum requirements that you need to be able to communicate over emmc um with the actual chip
so this is this is uh we're getting much lower than we normally do here on the pod because we mostly talk
about you know web and mobile stuff but this is actually talking about hardware level protocol stuff
which i think is really really fun to dive into um yeah but you know when once we start trying to
identify all those little pieces that's where we really need a logic analyzer versus a multimeter
because we have to be able to actually read the blips in in um power coming across those those various
um lines is that right yeah yeah so basically like what what the logic analyzer is going to be doing
is it's going to be looking at at shifts between high and low uh where that's basically like a high
voltage or a low voltage where it's either drawing where it's pulling it down or it's pushing it up and so
for example the clock pin that they identify super easy to identify that because it runs like a clock
right it goes on off on off on off on off on a very regular schedule and that's basically telling
the chip like how fast it should be operating and then data is for data and cmd is for telling it what
to do um and so you know it's it's basically as straightforward as that but logic analyzers will
make that so much easier just because a lot of the stuff that's built into the software will do it
automatically so in the article they use a sale a i use uh it's called a analog discovery 2 uh by
digiland um it's pretty good it's cheaper than a sale a but uh i think if i were to buy one again
i'd probably go with the sale a just because um it's a little bit higher spec it's a little bit more
expensive but the software is really really good and it's generally considered one of the top of the
the line tools that are out there um yeah digiland actually did just like last week announce um the
analog discovery 3 which is an improvement to what i have um it has i think faster polling rates
faster measurement rates it uses usbc instead of micro usb it's got a couple different things
um but uh but yeah no any any sort of like logic analyzer is going to be a good investment if you're
doing this type of hardware hacking just to identify like what's what's going on is this pin
you are is this pin jtag sure is this nothing like what is it yeah that that yeah that's a good point
i i think i got a little i get a little excited about this stuff and i jump right in let me let me just
say you know this is relevant to you all as bug bounty hunters out there you know the majority of our
audiences are active you know active bug bounty hunters because this is a very very untouched scope
normally like if you can go ahead because one because the tools are very expensive and you know
what we talk about here on the pod you invest the money you get the tools you buy the premium
you know and it opens up a bunch of scope that pays for itself um and in a lot of these hardware
hacking programs out there on hacker one or bug crowd you know you have to buy the piece of hardware
yourself and then you're going to break it and it's going to be annoying um but if you go through that
um that difficulty if you pay the price the bounties are much higher so i'm hoping that we can inspire
some of you to sort of pivot into the hardware hacking realm um it's really fascinating and there
are a lot of really good write-ups out there actually on it um and so and it's not as as hard as
you would think to pivot into it yeah and i think one of the things i would recommend if you or somebody
that you know has a background in electrical engineering yeah this is a great space to dig into
because like a fundamental electrical engineering background is so helpful for just understanding
some of the basic stuff like why are things behaving the way they are uh how how would i interface with
this if i want to read data off of this pin do i need to like have a pull down resistor what is a
pull down resistor right like there are like so many fundamental electronic questions that would be
so much easier to answer if you have any sort of electronics background it doesn't even have to be
like a full like electrical engineering background if you've done basic electronics stuff for many years
maybe even lots of people have yeah like robotics any of that kind of stuff working with the electronics
you're familiar with like voltages um like how circuit boards are designed created built all that kind of
stuff like this is a great area there's not a lot of people who know this kind of stuff it's a very like
sparse knowledge space within hacking so good yeah yeah like if you can pop one of these devices
it usually pays like a significant amount of money because most of these are owned by like large conglomerates
they have a lot of money on the line they have a lot of people with this device in their hands yeah and
there's just a skill set mismatch too right there's not as many people that can do hardware hacking stuff
as there are web because it requires tools it requires background knowledge um and so i think i think
you know the competition is is a little bit less and there's more of a demand you know supply and demand
just sort of dictates that the bounties would be higher yeah yeah and i also just wanted to mention um
two things on on what you just said one this is a great um reference to uh the conversation that corbin
and i had last week on the pod and we'll link that in the in the description but um we have a great
conversation about what kind of degree is best for a hacker to get and this is you know this conversation
we're having with joel here is one of the main reasons why i suggest a computer engineering or even
maybe even electrical engineering degree for some hackers because you get a lot lower level understanding of
you have the bottom bricks right you know think of it think of it you know sometimes if you're trying
to get an understanding of things you don't know what's happening underneath you kind of got this
very shaky understanding you're very shaky base and then you're trying to build bricks on top of it
but if you have a solid base then it becomes so much easier to just boom build up the wall
and and you've got a great understanding i don't know man i have a little bit of a self-consciousness
about my analogies because where i always like justin that analogy doesn't make any sense but
hopefully that one hopefully that one came through to you guys no no i i 100 know what you mean like
i i i get that same scent where especially with hardware hacking i'll be honest like hardware hacking is
that for me as well because i'll be like working on something and i'll be so confused as to why it's not
working and a lot of the time it's just because i've made a simple mistake due to a lack of fundamental
knowledge or understanding and it's very hard to find those problems or answer those like
unknown questions without the knowledge right so like i think this applies to like beginner hackers
as well it's like how do you know when to draw the line to stop hacking and move on how do you know when
you have no experience and no like knowledge or context like when to draw that line do you just guess
right like is there any sort of like concrete identifier and that that is very similar for like
hardware hacking where it's like how do you know if like this is just a fundamental thing that like
you need to go learn or if this is just a common problem that even the experts hit or like what is
going on here where do you draw the line so i wouldn't beat yourself up too much over it but if you
have that solid fundamental knowledge that that solid foundation is going to make things so much easier
yeah and and i think the the procrastination education uh piece with hardware hacking is a little bit
different too because sometimes you really do need to be like ah actually i don't know about this very
specific little thing for example we were joel and i were working on a on a project where we needed to
read from an rpmb sort of uh it's not really a protected memory block uh you know on an emc chip and uh we
we had never even heard of that so we both had to go and like read the white paper on that specific
you know piece of technology and kind of understand what it does at a lower level to be able to come
back and hack so it there's definitely some some some different tricks you know in the hardware hardware
hacking field that that to get caught up on but if you can pull it off one you know i i i would i don't
think i'll ever forget this moment in my entire life joel that first time we took the chip off of there
and i put it into my computer and i just saw like 15 different partitions like new disk new disk new disk
new disk found i was like you've got to be kidding me it's so satisfying like i cannot believe i just
pulled i took this to put device apart i took the chip out of the device and i put it into uh you know
a thing and my computer just read it like that's nuts so there's there's lots of really amazing
feelings that kind of come along with uh you know diving into hardware hacking and you know finding your
first little pathway to getting source code or uh you know a bug so yeah dude i'm not gonna lie even
after all that reading on rpmbs dude no one it's still like i don't even know like i i don't know if
i could describe like what it like what it is how it works like how it's supposed to be like if we did
anything right there because like when we eventually got on the on the device while it was running we could
access it but after we pulled the chip we couldn't so i don't know it's still very confusing to me but
it's it's a super interesting topic area yeah it's you know it's replay protected memory block right so
it it replay oh that's what it's replay protected memory block and and so essentially the whole point
of that is like you shouldn't be able to write to that block without um having some some going through
the authentication protocol but there's a bunch of things that say online because the spec is a little
fuzzy about whether you can read from that without having the authentication key and really if you
read the actual doc the actual spec for the for the device it shows that the encryption piece of rpmb
is just um an a hmac on the read side right so you know if you don't choose to validate that that mac then uh you know you can read from it just fine
um and it's mostly i think it's designed to um protect against tampering um at a hardware level
so anyway it's a cool thing i do i do know a lot more about it now than i than i did before
um so that's that's cool but you know i don't know when that will ever come in handy again next time i'm
doing like this is one of those little brain brain space fillers exactly exactly okay so getting back
so we look around on the board for test pins um see if we can hook up to those test pins see if we can
figure out some way to get at you know power up the chip uh via vcc or you know maybe i think in the
article yeah we'll definitely yeah definitely check out the article because there's still like some
stuff they mentioned here about glitching with the cpu to like try to get it to not try to read over that
that um you know read that disk so maybe there's some cool stuff you can do there yeah yeah you
could definitely do do some like power glitching and stuff to try and get the cpu in a weird state
um i do generally like trying to power it with the onboard power stuff okay uh if i can so for
example if i'm trying to use like you art or something yeah i definitely want to have it do
it's normal i basically want the device to think that everything is normal and it's getting all the
same you know power delivery and everything that it would while functioning normally instead of trying
to rig that myself i probably could but i don't know if something's going to go wrong right i don't
know if there's special power requirements that the chip is doing or that other things on the board
might need and the last thing you want to do is fry something on the board accidentally because
there's so much that's like the biggest risk in my opinion is that you fry something in an expensive
piece of hardware and then you have to buy another one or call it quits yeah that those are nice and
sometimes hacker one and i assume bug crowd does this too but i haven't had that experience with
bug crowd so i don't know they do okay um yeah it's because bug crowd doesn't know that i can hack
hardware i need to hit them up and be like hey by the way he submits one bug a year on bug
crowd then it's like hardware god no um yeah but you know it's really nice when the hacker one programs
and the bug crowd programs actually send you the hardware to test on without you having to pay for it
okay so we talked about the logic analyzer we talked about a little bit of recon so
let's say for example we can't get the test pin to work test pin method um with our sort of natural power
and we can't get it to power up you know you giving it power directly so we got to go for a chip pull um
and yeah so there are some there's some equipment that we need for this um and i kind of noted some
of them down here joel you can kind of take a quick look over that make sure i wasn't missing anything but
uh the essentials are a heat a heat sort of a heat gun or a heat hot air station i think is what they're
called and um and that will allow you to just very send very focused hot air on the specific chip so you
know you strip down the device you find the emmc chip um and you can find that by googling you know
what text is on it and sometimes it's obvious from the way that it looks but yeah you know you set that
hot air station up you shoot hot air on it and then what happens yeah so basically for like the mental
image for people who are just listening a hot air station is if you've seen a heat gun it's not like a
blow dryer it's like just the like straight part of a blow of a blow dryer without the handle and it
basically is just an electric coil that blows hot air and then it has these little funnels on the end
like you mentioned that like narrow the hot air down to like a very you can see yes you're pointing
at it right i'm sorry for those on youtube you can actually see it on my on my desk yes but for those
of you on audio listen to joel sorry yeah so there's like a little you know it's like a giant pen kind of
thing and it's wired up to this power supply and then on the power supply you set what temperature you
want it to run at and then there's a little nozzle on the end that controls how
you can see how large of an airflow that it's it's pushing hot air out and then just as a fan
overall heating element and it just blows hot air okay and this hot air can go very very hot very
very very hot easily burn yourself very very very very hot so this is not something to like just
you know mess around with obviously be careful with as you're using these tools
um you know respect respect what it can do it is a heat gun it creates heat you can get burned i have
gotten burned yes yeah me as well yes i uh i had a hot plate that i was now i was also doing some
desoldering with it i just like stuck my hand on it by accident i forgot it was on so that was fun um
but yeah so a hot gun a heat gun a hot air hot air reflow rework station it's called a lot of different
things we'll link some stuff down in the description for for those of you that kind of want a basic setup
yeah but what you need to what all you need to know is that basically chips generally speaking
have two different forms they have pins that are like coming off of the side of them that are then
soldered down to the board and then they have these things called a bga a ball grid array and a bga is
essentially little tiny uh balls of solder that connect underneath they like it literally sit it's
sandwiches on top there's the chip then there's balls of solder and then there's the board right
underneath it and there's contacts on the board underneath it so cool and it holds it you know once
the solder is not melted it holds it they're essentially acting as the pins that connects it between the
the the contacts on the bottom of the chip and the contacts on top of the board um and so when we use
a hot air gun we're essentially heating up that saw those little balls of solder underneath such that
they liquefy enough and then you pull the chip off and that's it like that that's basically all you're
doing you're doing what you would do with a soldering gun or soldering iron sorry like you know the hot
tip thing and you know you put it on whatever it smokes and it's all that but it's just like from
a distance right so you're just doing it with with hot air yeah yep with hot air yeah and so you know
i guess more more concretely you know you get the hot hot air station and you're you're kind of using
that pen and you're going back and forth and back and forth and um i think the last time we did an
assessment joel we set it to about 400 degrees celsius um but i think the best way to do it to preserve
the safety for the devices excuse me is to set it at like a lower level maybe like 250 or so
and then sort of slowly work your way up so you know you shoot it you know back and forth back and
forth for about a minute and a half two minutes and then you know you try to lift the chip and it's you're
not going to be forcing it it's literally just going to be a lift like you're going to put the grab your
tweezers that's another thing you need you're going to grab your tweezers you're going to grab the
chip with tweezers and you're going to try to lift up and if it doesn't come with you don't
force it and then you you know sort of back off let the chip cool down a little bit because you
don't want to fry it so maybe wait two or three minutes and then you know bump up the heat to 275 or
300 or something like that um and then sort of work your way up um i think the place we found it was
around 400 425 maybe is a good spot um and then eventually you know you do that for sometimes it's not
even 30 seconds sometimes it's like you know a shorter amount of time and you'll be able to just
lift the chip right off um and then you've done a successful pull hopefully if you didn't rip off any
pads yeah so i'm sure that there are some some like hardware people cringing cringing as they
listening to this being like 400 degrees 425 yeah um so the one one thing i'll say is most of these hot air
guns are
made cheaply and they do not have the best quality control and they're not the most consistent things
especially across brands and across devices so your mileage is going to vary probably greatly from
someone else's and you will just need to do some testing on your own um like justin said i would
start at a low temp like start at melting point of solder so like probably around 200c and just work your way
up if you're you know you're constantly moving your air gun you're heating the whole area the the thing
that you mentioned this but you didn't really explain it you need to be constantly moving the air gun
around the chip because you need all of the balls of solder underneath the chip to be melted at the
same time yeah that's very important right and the other thing is flux oh my god flux is your best friend
yeah so yeah so flux paste flux all it basically it helps solder this is not really optional i i you
know this is very important yes you need flux like big time so flux helps solder uh flow it helps
prevent it from oxidizing and so essentially what that's going to do uh solder has surface tension
essentially that's what holds it in place um when justin said that the chip will be very easy to pull
off it it's like a water bug on top of a surface of water really good analogy the chip is basically
magnated in place because there are copper contacts underneath it and there are copper contacts
on the top of the chip and the balls of solder that are between it are surface tension to those
those pieces of copper and it's holding like if you were to bump the chip it would snap back basically
because the solder is holding it in place if it's doing that that means it's ready to lift so your goal
is that you want all the solder to be liquid enough that you can basically bump the chip and see it wiggle
and then just lift it and it's very there should be no force you're you're not peeling you're not you're
not sort of you know starting at one side and like sort of lifting it up a little bit no you're gonna break
the chip that way don't don't do that yeah it's really you know very lightly and you know maybe not even
with the pointed tip of your tweezers because you don't want to like scratch it or like you know cause
any damage to the chip you're just kind of gently pushing against it and if you like jill said if you
don't see that sort of um movement then it's not ready to pull so yeah there's a lot of really good
videos well actually there's not there's a couple really good videos yeah i was gonna say i don't think
so yeah yeah uh you'll find i think a lot of these are more like for repair and they don't they don't care
so much about the integrity of the chip that they're pulling off um and that's fine uh it's like a
demonstration but just keep that in mind with temperature right like generally speaking if you
were to read the spec sheet for these chips these chips are not designed to be in environments that
are above probably like 100 degrees fahrenheit or like you know 30 degrees celsius or something
meanwhile we're heating them up to like 200 400 degrees celsius so you know part of that is that
that's the direct temperature coming out of the gun but that's not the temperature that's hitting
the chip and that's also why we want to move it around and we want to keep
constant flow so that all that heat isn't targeted into one specific place it's going to fry or melt
stuff within the chip um so yeah those tweezers super useful if you look at any videos online you're
going to see basically lots of flux lots of moving the heat gun around eventually you know they'll tap
it they'll tap it with like some really fine point tweezers and they'll see that it moves and then they
just grab the edges of it and just lift it up um you know microscopes some people really like to do it under
microscope some people like to do it under like a magnifying glass some people like to just do with
their eyeballs depending on the size of the chip you may or may not need to do that um you know it's
really it's really up to you and your your eyesight i guess but um i do it without a microscope the other
thing is for those of you watching on youtube again you can see over my shoulder this this little device
that joel uh you know freaking influenced me into buying um it's called what is it called is it handy
hands that's it yeah and it's got like these these little sort of for those of you listening it's sort
of like dock ox style um you know flexible arms that kind of grip the the uh the actual board and then
they have sort of a magnifying glass light and they've got like a little uh clamp there that you
can use to hold the board and it's it's just got some nice things that make the whole process go
smoother um and so i would recommend those uh that made it a lot easier for me i know when i because i
didn't have that uh when joel and i were doing my first pull i was actually trying to uh heat up the
chip on top of a heat sink to keep it slack and i was and joel was like dude what are you doing no
stop um yeah and so uh yeah definitely definitely a good recommend there um yeah and then any kind
of handy hands is really good yeah the really good product i i really like it um and then so once you
pull the chip off you got to clean it and you got to clean it better than you think you got to
clean it um just coming from a beginner's perspective here because i was like ah you know
this is probably fine now you really want to take the time with isopropyl alcohol and a q-tip
and you know gently with some tweezers and you know you want to put uh i think you joel even use
like uh the tip of a soldering um iron and sort of drag some some flux or some uh some solder around
on it right yeah yeah so it's called reflowing and basically you take like you know a larger than normal
blob of solder and you can just heat it up and and get it so it's it's like now it's kind of yeah it's
melted but it's it's stuck to the end of your um soldering iron tip and then you just want to glide
that ball of solder over the contacts over the the copper contacts on the bottom side of the chip after
you removed it and that's going to one pick up any extra solder that that is on those pins and it's
also going to uh put a thin layer of solder back on top of any ones that don't have solder on them so
it's going to basically like clean up it's going to uniformly uniform yeah right right right and then
you just you know lift it off and you should have your big blob of solder still on your nice your your
iron and that's going to help prevent any contacts from getting bridged any of that kind of stuff
the uh the flux yeah isopropyl alcohol the higher percentage the better 99 if you can get it 91 is
probably what you'll find at like a store or something um but yeah just a q-tip uh or a
cotton swab or anything like that um you know just be aware that it can leave like little fibers behind
yeah i don't like that yeah yeah so just be aware of that um you know some q-tips are less fibrous than
others i guess less hairy than others so yeah what i did when i was doing it was i actually pulled off a
little bit of the hair you know and kind of made it a little bit less hairy you know when i first
started using the q-tip and then you know that sort of got it to drop less fibers so or maybe even
you could like you know twist it in your in your hand and try to compact some of that down
so that it doesn't leave as many fibers on there because that is a pain to get off afterwards i think
maybe i used a microfiber cloth or something like that at one point to try to get this off
yeah something like that so yeah reflowing it and using isopropyl to clean any excess flux
those are the two ways that i generally clean the bottom of a chip if you're having a read
problem with a chip and it looks like visibly like there's no defects in the chip there's no physical
damage all the contacts look like they're intact it doesn't look like any of them have been ripped
off or anything like that clean it again just that's number one i just say clean it again because
we had that happen both on my side and justin's side where a chip wasn't reading properly in the
reader took some more iso just cleaned it one more time there must have been like a thin layer of flux
or something that was you know interrupting their yeah i don't know but uh yeah that fixed it and that
last one that last poll that you did on the last exercise or in the last you know thing we were working
on like it was i mean he was holding it up to the you know to the webcam and it looked like it just came
out of the factory man it was like clean as could be so that's the goal yes it was mint um so that was
that was really cool um and then one of the other things i just wanted to mention we're going back you
know so well actually we'll go back after let's let's go ahead and finish this up so you clean it
and then we're going to go ahead and put it in a emmc chip reader um there are quite a few different
devices out there um the only one i have experience using is not on my desk right now but it's it's an
all socket emmc reader um very easy to use it has a bunch of uh nice little uh plastic fittings you can
use for different sizes of emmcs it does not we did run into an issue last time where it actually didn't
have the right plastic size um to get it to read which was kind of a pain but um uh we found another
way to do it so that was good um but yeah so that's one option and then i know people also use something
called a t56 um yeah uh let me pull it up universal programmer um and i've had that so yeah so i have
both of these the bga so the all socket bga emmc reader super super useful like you mentioned it
basically has different base plates that will hold it over the right pin like the pin readers within
the socket adapter um the thing to note about that is one it's quite expensive for like it's a very
targeted tool so it's designed for i think it's bga 159 or something or 186 or i mean let me pull it
up real quick yeah and and when he says it's very expensive i mean it's it's in the hundreds range not in
the thousands range because i i'll just throw it out there it was 87 but it's it's just this adapter
right 87 plus eight dollars of shipping um and it's designed for uh emmc fbga 153 and 169. okay
so specifically that's like those are two different form factors of chip uh it might refer to like the
number of no it doesn't it can't be the number of solder but it's it's it's like it's a specific form
factor of chip basically and you'll see like if you're reading the data sheet that there will be
different form factors for different chips a lot of them will fall into the same categories but as
just mentioned for example we pulled a bga chip that was i think it was a bga 153 but it wasn't the right
you know size dimensions it didn't have the face plate to hold it in the adapter so you know we
couldn't read it very easily um and i had even tried like 3d printing an adapter to fit it in there and it
didn't it didn't really work that well yeah yeah that was that was uh that was a little bit of a bummer
so definitely you know if you're going to buy specialized equipment for a specific thing you
know i think these all socket emmc readers will cover the large majority of the ones but you know
you got to know you may run into a situation and you may want to measure the size of the chip beforehand
in millimeters and make sure it supports that form factor um i do want to say
i said it just a second ago but you know joel said they're expensive there are some things on
amazon that are selling these things for like two and a half grand that is not what we're asking you
to buy do not buy that um they're they're they're cheaper options i think it was like yeah a hundred
dollars or sub a hundred dollars so we'll link some of those down in the description um you know you
can find them on some of them you can find on amazon some of them you can find on some of the other
websites um so definitely don't go and spend like two and a half grand for one of these things
because it's ridiculous yeah yeah for the t56 that's really good um for like yeah yeah so that's
good for like nand flashes and stuff it has different use cases generally when i use that
uh well a nand is just like a basic like part of a chip it's like a an electronic like structure but
um a nand flash it's just a different type of flash okay as opposed to an emmc or nand flood they're
different types of flashes nor flashes um but uh you can buy these large sets of adapters so i have
a huge box that's full of just like uh every type of t sop like t sop 48 t sop 56 like every single
you know t sop or sop adapter that you can think of and then on the bottom it has these little pins
that they're just you know pin headers and essentially you clamp it in this t56 and then you plug
it into your computer and you can read it um and it's just you know it's a different way of mounting
it um generally the all socket one i'm using for bga stuff i suppose you probably could do bga stuff
this way with the t56 yeah it says it says um if you hear i'll send it to you right now on discord if
you if you look at the third item down um it's it says supports bga 45 63 64 100 53 162 169 221 so i
think you know it definitely has a wide range of bga that it's compatible with yeah yeah so i think the
main thing is you just have to get the right adapters for it um i'm not i'm honestly not sure like how
this thing works like every time i've ever used it i just plug it in and uh it it it either has the
chip in the software it doesn't and uh it just like yeah i don't know it's uh it's kind of weird but
it's pretty it's pretty useful yeah so this could be a good one a good one um to check out and add to
your to your arsenal as well i think probably all together i spent maybe five or six hundred dollars
on sort of like a beginner setup for all of this stuff um when i was first starting out um so you
know definitely it's not cheap to get into it but also now i've got the tools that i'll use in the
future as well um so that's that's pretty helpful yeah yeah hardware hacking is one of those things
where you could easily spend a couple thousand dollars on on tools and still not have the right
thing that you need so i would just say do a lot of research before you buy stuff especially
specifically for your use case so like what specific chip do you want to use this tool for
is it going to work for that chip and don't be surprised if it doesn't work for other chips um
just that's kind of just the way it is uh if you can find some of those more generic tools
sometimes they're more expensive and they'll require some more like
effort on your side in terms of like programming or like maybe you'll have to write something custom
to interface with it but those tools will let you interface with almost anything nice yeah that's
awesome i i definitely value that flexibility a little bit because it's nothing there's nothing
worse than like you sit down on a weekend and you're ready to go and you're like all right i'm
just gonna hack this and you get like an hour in and you're like i don't actually have the thing that
i need yes that's a pain um all right so you cleaned it you put it in your reader um like
joel mentioned in the beginning there's a little um dot at the corner of a lot of the emc chips that
uh show you where the number one pin is and you'll want to align that with the arrow on your um
all socket emmc reader if you're using that and uh sort of clamp it down slide it right into a uh a sd
card slot either on your computer ideally your computer has a uh emmc reader built in at a sort of
internal uh chip level rather than using like a usb thing but the usb things will work as well
unless you're trying to access some specific features that only a emmc reader can access
rather than an sd card reader because they are sort of cross-compatible but emmc has some features
that sd can't handle i think right yeah so like the rpmb stuff that we talked about like that is one of
those specific things where you need an mmc controller that is in like on your device in
order to interface with something like that they sell pcie ones that are there are like proper mmc
controllers but most of the time you're going to find it needs to be like an onboard s full-size sd
reader on your computer on like a laptop or something and even then a lot of times it won't
um if you use like a usb reader usb like sd readers they are basically just storage interfaces
for mmc so they have an mmc controller on the you know in the usb adapter or whatever but when you
plug that in all it's doing is exposing those storage interfaces so it's going to be all the
storage partitions but you're not going to have access to the raw mmc like rpmb and any of those other
like special mmc type things unless you have an onboard mmc controller so if all you need to do is
read data partitions totally fine if you need to read rpmb normally yes normally speak like 99 of
cases you'll probably be fine but if you want to try and get at rpmb or any any of that kind of stuff
you're going to need an onboard mmc controller yeah yeah so now you've you've got it hooked up you're
seeing the partitions pop in what um what we did last time is we just used the dd command in linux
to just pull an a raw you know device level image of that device into an image um file and then we
ended up using uh was it seven seven zip yeah seven zip to go ahead and um break that out into the
individual partitions and then you know you'll see various files created and if you run file on them
you'll see like uh you know there's a there's an ext4 ext4 yeah or like a fat partition or whatever you
know there's going to be a bunch of different positions because that's always what
it they have in a bunch of these iot devices but um you know identifying all of those various uh
partitions is really fun and and this kind of pivots into the last section that i wanted to cover
which is like um joel what kind of like preventions have you seen from this because the only one that
kind of comes to my head was like man we would have been in in trouble if they um stuck all of the
source code or like the file system for that device inside of that lux um encrypted partition that we
that we saw for some of the more sensitive data and then um and then you you know stored the key for
that luxe encrypted partition in in a secure on gave in at like a hardware level at the cpu or something
like that um that would have been a royal pain in the butt to get access to um so i mean there's that
option i imagine that would sort of delay startup quite a bit because every time you wanted to use the
device you'd have to um decrypt everything on the partition and then also copy that into an actual
functioning partition um so that might affect the boot speed a little bit but what other kind of
hardware level preventions have you seen that might you know foil a hacker yeah so like you mentioned
like that kind of stuff that's going to be like 99 of the time is going to stop like a lot of what
you're trying to do you're going to have to find some other attack scenario you're if you want like
a shell or something like that to figure out like what it's doing you're going to need to like glitch
it or maybe you'll have to read the mmc while it's running or something like that right like this is
one of those cases where that might actually be the right scenario um but yeah uh an encrypted partition
would stop like pretty much all the stuff that we were we were doing there um another thing that
you see commonly and this isn't for storage so much as it is for like debugging stuff but there's
typically there'll be like a fuse either within a chip or on the board um and it's typically called
like a jtag fuse or a uart or a debug fuse or something and they'll they'll basically pop the
fuse by like putting enough power to it and then it can never be reverted so it'll it has a physical
break in the communication between like your test pins and the jtag interface on the chip and you can't
get around that unless you like i don't know do some like really crazy like yeah pulling the chip apart
like i don't know like cut into the chip and like get access which i've seen by the way yeah that would
that would be gnarly that's interesting though that that that's a counter measure that that people might
take you know just kind of putting a fuse in there and blowing it you know severs the connection for that
sort of thing that's a good idea yeah i've seen um there's a couple really interesting twitter
threads out there i'm trying to remember who created them but um every once in a while you'll
see like some crazy hardware hacker just like put a video of what they what they're working on like
on twitter and this one time there's this guy he was using a razor blade uh to scratch away the surface
of a chip while it was on the board to expose the context underneath and then he took like you know
probably i don't know speaker speaker wire i don't even know like uh you know like uh maybe like a
a coil wire or something like really really fine wire like wire wire gauge wire and and then like
uh i think he soldered it down so it wouldn't move and then he soldered the like tip of it to to like
the contact on the chip dude it was so crazy i gotta i'll find it we'll put in the show notes yeah no
definitely find that i want to see that and i know i watched a um a talk at defcon by lenner i think is
uh is the guy that did it uh hardware hacking guy um you know just glitching uh i think it was some
spacex or stuff or some whatever their their wi-fi thing is that's everywhere um just absolutely amazing
so there's so much to learn about in this space which really excites me as a as a more veteran hacker in
the in the web and in mobile space a little bit now um you know having another realm to dive deep
into is really is really cool so i'm excited to continue learning about that sort of thing and be
able to do some some glitching and and some uh some of the stuff that i haven't uh tackled next time
around yeah for sure i mean there's this space is like i feel like i've just barely scratched the
surface in terms of knowledge and understanding and and what's possible and all that kind of stuff
and i feel like i'm just just like i'm doing like you know baby's first hardware hacking right now so
like there's so much so much i i don't know and there's so much i haven't explored that that seems
so cool well it's very different too you know and if you talk to some of these lower level guys they
they don't have any uh you know experience doing web stuff and so it's just different realms and
different sections of places where people are are focusing and so it's cool to get some sort of
cross experience it makes you really feel like a more well-rounded or developed hacker i think
um i did want to add a disclosure at the end here um this does not constitute a vulnerability so
um being able to pull the operating system off of a chip i personally don't believe uh constitutes a
vulnerability um i've seen some hackers report that i'm not sure whether they got paid or not um but
you know there's not a really great countermeasure to it and um and so it's just kind of a part of
hardware hacking and more like finding javascript files in in um in web stuff or more like uh decompiling
an apk and grabbing at the the java source code you know uh in mobile um so definitely definitely
don't go and like once you get your chip and you pull the data off of it don't go report it like
critical you know source code disclosure because i believe most of the time that is uh something that
is not going to get accepted by the program so there's your disclaimer yes yeah for sure and i i
agree i've actually i've seen people report this exact thing as as a bug and uh it's personally it's not
something that i would report uh either but i do see that there is a security risk to it uh i think
it i would probably just like it's a really hard attack scenario to like justify is like you know
to say like oh it's a higher crit or something that's a really hard thing to justify depending on
what it is depending on what it is there are certainly hardware devices like cell phones that
are in like so many people's hands and pockets that that might be a justifiable attack scenario but i think
just in and of itself having a decrypted partition maybe not enough yeah totally agree yeah all right
man uh that's all i had on the notes for this episode uh you got anything else or are we gonna
wrap it up here nope that's it i did find those links so we'll put them in the show notes be sure to
check out the those links one is from uh g torix and one is from hacking things uh both on twitter i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go look those up right now i will say as we're headed out um so many of you uh
went over to the website after last episode criticalthinkingpodcast.io and dropped your email
on the newsletter super appreciate that would love if you continue to do that um and also please
remember naham khan uh that that is let me pull up the dates briefly i want to say it's june 15th to
17th um yeah yes it is june 15th to 17th the saturday is when i'll be speaking at the 12 20 slot
you won't want to miss out on that lots of great talented bug bounty hunters there dropping some
amazing presentations so we'll uh we'll see you there yes so start remember starts one week from
the drop of this episode so yep be sure to tune in if you want to hear a little bit more justin and
some other awesome john hammond's going to be there so yeah super super awesome security
conference go check it out for sure all right catch y'all next week peace all right peace
Thank you.